- GO FOR IT, MAN.
- OKAY, GOOD.
GOOD, GOOD, GOOD.
OH, THAT'S NUTS, MAN.
- OKAY, WE GOT TO HURRY UP.
BRING ON THE WEED.
- OKAY, JUST GOT TO--
- BREAK IT OUT THERE.
- HEY.
- OH!
- SORRY.
SORRY.
- YOU ALL WANT TO DO
SOME OF THAT GOD DRUG?
[violin screeching eerily]
♪ ♪
- NO.
- WHAT THE [bleep]?
- WHO'S THIS GUY?
- YOU ALL EVER HEARD
OF THE GOD DRUG?
- I'VE--I'VE NEVER
HEARD OF THAT.
- AKA SLAYER, CUTTY-CUTTY,
DOUBLE CUTTY, ELMO, CAT VAG.
- OKAY.
- LONG ISLAND BRAIN SLICE,
FUNT.
- FUNT?
- FUNT.
- FUNT, I'VE HEARD OF THAT.
- IT TAKES ALL YOUR GREATEST
FEARS AND INSECURITIES,
AND IT GIVES THEM
TEETH AND ARMS,
AND THEN IT LOCKS YOU
IN A ROOM WITH THEM
FROM WHICH YOU CANNOT ESCAPE.
- OH, THAT SOUNDS TERRIBLE.
- YEAH, I DON'T WANT THAT, MAN.
- NONE OF THOSE WORDS ARE GOOD.
- YOU REALIZE THE FACE OF GOD
IS SOMEWHERE INSIDE YOUR BODY,
BUT YOU CAN'T FIND IT,
AND IT HATES YOU.
- UM, OKAY, NONE OF US ARE
INTERESTED IN THIS DRUG.
THANK YOU, SIR.
NICE MEETING YOU.
- LET'S HEAR HIM OUT.
LET'S HEAR HIM OUT.
- IT'S A RAZOR SHARP CRYSTAL
YOU TUCK UNDER YOUR EYELID.
- OOH.
- UGH.
- AND THEN WHEN YOUR OCULAR
CAVITY STARTS BLEEDING,
IT GOES DIRECTLY
INTO YOUR BRAIN.
- I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S GOT TO BE A GOOD PART.
- YEAH, YOU'VE JUST DESCRIBED
A LIFE-WRECKING
PHYSICAL ADDICTION.
- IF YOU'D LET HIM FINISH--
IF YOU'D LET HIM FINISH,
HE'S GONNA GET TO
THE EUPHORIA, I'M SURE.
- JUST WHEN YOU CAN'T TAKE
ANY MORE,
[inhales sharply]
YOU POOP YOUR MOUTH.
- I'M SORRY, WHAT?
- YOU POOP IN YOUR MOUTH?
- NO,
YOU POOP OUT OF YOUR MOUTH.
- I'M IN.
GUYS, IF PEOPLE WILL
REALLY GO THROUGH THIS,
THE HIGH MUST BE AMAZING.
- BUDDY,
REMEMBER WHEN YOU DID MUSHROOMS
AND YOU CRIED FOR THREE HOURS?
THIS IS WORSE THAN THAT.
- YEAH.
- OH, THE EYES.
OH, OH!
[yelling]
OH, GOD!
[both groaning]
- IT HURTS!
- OH, JEB.
- OH, THAT HURTS!
WHEN DOES IT START WORKING?
- HOW SHOULD I KNOW?
I DON'T DO DRUGS.
DRUGS ARE FOR LOSERS.